لا اعرف ان هناك جناح منفتح وحتى ان كان
موجود فبنسبه لهم اطاعه الامير افضل من
اطاعه الله جل وعلى و نحن نعلم جيدا لا
تعطي لمخلوق في معصيه الخالق حتى وان
كانوا موجودين فالسكوتهم يعتبر بانهم
ليسوا موجودين والساكت عن الحق شيطان
الاخرس فان كان هناك موجود نعم هناك بعض
اظهارات وبعد همم
اشياء صدرت عن بعض الاخوه في طالبان
وكانهم يستنكروا ولكن ليسوا بصراحه ولم
يقف في هذه الجنيه ويعلمون جيدا بان هذا
الامر يخالف الدين يخالف الشرع الشرعيه
يخالف همم الوسوس والاسس والقواعد وعادات
وتقاليد الافغانيه ويعرفون جيدا انما ان
لم يكون هناك شخص يرفع صوته فمعنى هذا انه
لا يوجد فان كان كان هناك همم شخص او
شخصين او اكثر او الفتح فليرفع الصوته
على انفسهم الا يخافون على انفسهم حتى ولو
كانوا من قيادات الطالبان من الامام من
القتل من الملاحقه من هذا الامر
ما اعلنه الشيخ هيبه الله العلماء
قالوا واعلن ان حتى لو لو لو استعملتم
علينا همم
القنبله النوويه نحن ما نحن عليه فلنت ما
فيها شيء
لا يخافوا
والسؤال الذي سالت الاستاذ احمد انه لماذا
اذ لم يصبر صنع سنتين وكانهم يعرفون ان
الوقت ليس في صالحهم وليس هناك فرصه ان
تستمر هذا هذه الحكومه وهذا النظام
سيريدون ان يطبقوا كل ما يريدونه والشعب
باجمله وهناك حتى ايضا حتى نكون الحقيقه
هناك بعض العلماء في داخل طالبان فضلت
الشيخ محمد رسول وهو عضو في دوله في في
مكتب قطر للطالبان صرح بكل صراحه وقال ان
منع طالبات حتى من الثانويه هذا يخالف
الشرع وهناك شيخ شجاع الدين خدام اعلن بكل
صراحه وحتى لو لو تتذكر السيد احمد يتذكر
ان وزير الامر بالمعروف قال ان العلوم
تعليم العلوم الاسريه مباحه فهذا الشيخ
الشجاع دين قال من يقول بان التعليم
المراه مباح فهو ينوب عن
اليهود نعم هناك مشائخ في داخل افغانستان
هناك مئات الاساتذه في الجامعات همم يعني
تركوا العمل وتركوا دراسه وقدموا
الاستقاله فهذا كل شيء الشعب كله وليس
الشعب الافغاني فقط حتى الاسس المؤسسات
الدينيه ودول الاسلاميه والعالم الاسلامي
باجمعه منظمه الدائمه
التعاون الاسلامي بلده العالم الاسلامي
الازهر
الاسلام